MALE SPEAKER: Introducing
ZYNC on Google Cloud Platform.
The tool for rendering
your imagination.
Now, you can spin up
processors as needed
to bring your ideas to life.
Simply choose your
processor, then render away
until your shot is complete.
Speed is key when rendering
high-resolution animation,
especially for 4K
and VR renders.
And remember, per-minute
billing equals major savings.
Get billed only for what you
use, never for what you don't.
Our plug-and-play
software makes cloud
rendering as easy as two steps.
With ZYNC on Google
Cloud Platform,
this cute little
creature has the power
to do just about anything.
Redeem up to $800 in credit to
tap the rendering power of ZYNC
on Google Cloud Platform.